[Music]
[Applause]
200 miles southwest of rainbow
proceeding on course to manland dr. star
this is the emergency can happen in many
ways but one thing is certain how well
you've learned to expect the unexpected
they determine the course of events that
follow
[Music]
this is the beginning of survival
problem now stay alive the second night
was the toughest I had no feeling of my
right foot I kept thinking they'd
amputate if they ever got me back every
time I loosen the bandage blood gushed
out I thought of letting it freeze but
decided against it it was just one of
those ideas you get at a time like that
[Music]
then at dawn of the third day the
weather began to close in to me this
meant one thing they wouldn't be able to
continue the search I'll admit I was
scared it was the way I felt when I
realized I had lost my survival gear
I've fought it off somehow told myself
to relax I have to go on believing they
find me with my fouled up leg I knew I
couldn't find them then I heard the
sound of the chopper but first I thought
my mind was playing tricks on me I've
been afraid of this all along but it was
up there alright then heading right for
me I tried to wave and yell the effort
was too much for me I felt myself
blacking up but they saw me the next
thing I remember was Sergeant Kerry
coming down the hoist Lieutenant Edward
Stuart Air Defense Command flameout
ejection and 45 hours of raw survival
alone 45 hours not a very long interval
of time but
poor lieutenant Stewart long enough to
suffer shock and pain from severe injury
long enough to know the meaning of
hunger thirst cold fatigue isolation
remoteness and fear from a technical
point of view these are survival
stresses your point of view their
obstacles you must avoid overcome or be
prepared to withstand if you want to
live and to complicate matters here are
a few more these stresses can occur in
all environments to a greater or lesser
degree already the desert in the tropics
and on water how these stresses might
develop how they might affect you are
the big questions you can wait find the
answers the hard way or you can profit
right now from the experience of the
thousands who face survival and lived
from what they faced and from what they
learned have come methods for
recognizing understanding and combating
survival stresses to pass this knowledge
along to you is one purpose of our
discussion and the other purpose is to
make you think about yourself and for
this very important reason if you find
yourself in a survival situation the
chances are you'll find yourself alone
so let's take a look at you the
individual a very complex creation you
are different from all others mentally
and emotionally but physically just
about the same when your body is
supplied with the essentials of life
growth and repair processes function
normally and sufficient energy is
created to enable you to perform
efficiently but when the body is
deprived of even one of the essentials
water for example your physical and
mental capabilities decrease and
eventually if corrective measures are
not taken this something to consider
isn't it but perhaps you're not
concerned right now because you're
fairly well-off and that where you are
life is pretty good so let's take you
from your comfortable environment to
another one one not so comfortable and
try to make the point that way this is
the desert no one can deny it's
fantastic beauty and no one can deny
that men have died here alone through a
turrets ignorance not only of practical
measures to take but ignorance of how
much stress their bodies could endure
sometimes they discovered this too late
about one-fifth of the land area of the
world is desert the odds against an
emergency over desert terrain are in
your favor but it could happen
what then will you be up against mainly
two things an excess of heat and a
scarcity of water and without water you
cannot survive for long for a simple
explanation of this let's take a look at
you
simplified your normal body temperature
is 98.6 degrees Fahrenheit to maintain
this temperature your body has an
effective and efficient cooling
mechanism the evaporation of sweat on
the skin surface by this process excess
heat absorbed or generated by the body
is dissipated and you will continue to
sweat as long as the need exists to hold
body temperature down in desert areas
the amount of sweat produced can be
considerable
this is also true in humid environments
where in complete evaporation interferes
with heat dissipation but the bulk of
sweat is water and every bit of it must
be replaced because every bit of it is
needed for normal bodily functions if it
is not replaced your body will go into
debt for water by withdrawing water from
vital parts when the bloodstream gives
up water the blood becomes thicker and
less in volume the heart has to work
faster to pump the thickened blood
through the arteries and veins and as
water loss continues it becomes
increasingly difficult for your body to
function what you have just seen on the
screen is the process of dehydration
understanding its effect on you is
important but important to is knowing
how to recognize it let's investigate
this further approximately 2/3 of the
human body is water this level must be
maintained if you were to live work and
think at peak efficiency when this water
level begins to drop you become thirsty
and uncomfortable
you begin to move in a kind of slow
motion you have no appetite as you lose
more water you get sleepy your
temperature goes up you get irritable
eventually you become nauseous dizziness
difficulty in breathing and a tingling
sensation in the arms and legs follow
when your body has lost only 10% of its
body weight in water
you can't move about normally at this
point locating a water source may be
impossible and when water loss continues
death is inevitable not a very happy
thought is it well let's see what you
can do to keep the worst from happening
conserve your sweat not your water drink
all you want as long as it's available
stay in the shade off the ground ground
temperature maybe 150 degrees or higher
even here travel only at night
move slowly take it easy
those were a few hints on water
conservation but they represent only a
fraction of the information you must
know in order to survive in the desert
demonstrating how to locate water how to
find food how to orient yourself in the
desert or anyplace else is beyond the
scope of this discussion but you have
access to this information through
survival manuals by undergoing courses
in survival and by doing air force
training films sun sand survival is one
such film you saw a clip from it a
moment ago make a point
to see it in its entirety and make a
point to investigate other approved
sources of information Army and Navy
material for example you might be
surprised at how many misconceptions you
have about survival perhaps you have the
impression that water is a prime
requirement only in the desert it isn't
in order to maintain your water balance
in any environment you need
approximately two quarts of water a day
yes even here but this environment
presents another serious threat cold
cold intensified by wind
the two are a deadly combination of
elements which increases the rate of
cooling of the body sometimes
drastically scientists have a name for
it windchill but it's more than a word
of technical jargon it's a fact
you can't ignore it's a fact for example
that exposed flesh will freeze when the
temperature is minus 40 degrees
Fahrenheit and there is little or no
wind
now this doesn't surprise you does it
but wait let's raise the temperature to
15 degrees not too uncomfortable you've
all experienced this but increase the
wind velocity to 26 miles an hour and
the same result is produced raise the
temperature to 20 degrees increase the
wind to 43 miles an hour and again
exposed flesh will freeze and what about
the time for these and other
combinations to do the job one hour two
hours possibly but it could be only 30
seconds under more extreme conditions
such as these cold is an enemy of
survival a killer it has a way of
slipping up on you numbing mind and body
taking away efficiency and most of your
will except that part which says get
warm get warm yes get warm and stay warm
the most sensible idea you could have
but it takes more than an idea it takes
know-how knowing how to conserve body
heat
this in turn involves an understanding
of your body's heat system it is a
complicated system so again a
simplification blood would absorb food
and oxygen is circulated to the
different parts of the body every living
cell has the ability to burn food in the
presence of oxygen in the process energy
is created part of this energy is used
in doing work but most of it is
liberated as heat at the surface of the
body when you exercise or do work you
burn up more food stored in the muscles
this requires more oxygen to get it you
breathe faster and faster more heat is
then generated and the smaller blood
vessels near
the skin open wider circulation in the
skin is increased and heat loss is
faster in cold weather when the normal
rate of heat loss would result in
excessive cooling the circulation of the
blood through the skin is decreased by
constriction of the smaller blood
vessels this reduces the rate of heat
loss and preserves the heat for the
vital organs rather ingenious don't you
think but the system has a flaw in it
and for you a serious one when nature
cuts down circulation at skin surfaces
to conserve heat for your vital organs
she sacrifices other parts of the body
the hands feet toes nose ears face for
example as a consequence these are the
first to become frostbitten and remember
this situation and danger is not
confined to the Artic
it exists right here in the United
States some have failed to consider this
and die but wherever you are no matter
how cold you are the situation is far
from hopeless if you're willing to help
yourself here's how improvise use
materials you have available above all
conserve your body heat if you must
exercise or move about avoid sweating
sweating increases loss of body heat if
you sweat or get warm ventilate your
garments and keep your mind on survival
this is good advice anywhere anytime
when you're facing survival the things
you've always taken for granted have a
way of becoming terribly important and
sometimes out of proportion
when you're cold you can't think of
anything but warmth when you're thirsty
you can't think of anything but water
and when you're hungry you can't think
of anything but food but food is less
important than water or shelter being
hungry doesn't mean that you're on the
verge of starvation you can live for
quite a while without food but the time
might come when a little self-diagnosis
will reveal these symptoms you feel
tired and weak you don't think you have
the strength to go on
you get cold easily
you become annoyed short-tempered and
eventually you just don't care when you
feel that way mentally and physically
you're in a precarious position but
let's go back a bit how can this happen
there are three possibilities illness or
serious injury might prevent you from
foraging for food
you might lack the knowledge of how to
live off the land or you find things to
eat but you just can't stock them this
last is called food aversion or food
prejudice and for some it isn't easy to
overcome but when it's a matter of life
or death
you'll have to try you may have to try
mighty higher this is a sequence from
another Air Force training film jungle
survival
[Music]
obviously food aversion is not an
obstacle here if it was it's been
surmounted and this is what you'll have
to do no one can do it for you
[Applause]
food resources of different environments
varied but remember anything that creeps
watts swims or flies is a possible
source of food and if this makes a
vegetarian out of you there's always
this learn to live off the land begin
right now by experimenting with new
foods practice eating foods which are
not your favorites and learn to
appreciate them controlling hunger is
one of the easier problems to solve in
survival if you can adjust to discomfort
and adapt to primitive conditions and to
make it still easier here are a few
practical suggestions for cure both
water and food when you can still think
clearly forage for food save your
rations for emergency take stock of what
you have and plan accordingly don't
waste your energy stop and prepare your
food whenever you can the rest you get
is beneficial I don't think we have to
worry about here knowing the effects of
different stresses is essential but
often it's not a simple matter to
pinpoint the exact stress causing the
trouble
stresses have a way of interacting
producing symptoms which are almost
identical and to complicate your problem
further stresses physical and nature
have very definite psychological
implications
you just can't define a stress and say
here's where it begins here's where it
ends as a matter of fact there's one
stress for which no single definition is
adequate fatigue the number and variety
of activities which might produce
fatigue are countless it might even be
the result of trying to avoid a
situation too difficult to face
fatigue is cumulative it is evidenced by
a lack of staying power the short temper
impatience and a tendency to magnify
minor troubles weather fatigue is mental
or physical is debatable but its effects
are essentially the same and as far as
you're concerned it's something else
you'll have to combat so again here are
a few suggestions that might help assess
the situation have a plan and follow it
this is always the best idea channel
your activities in the most useful
direction don't overestimate your
strengths set up a programme of rest if
possible and whatever you do concentrate
on the positive not the negative yes
concentrate on the positive not the
negative don't let your imagination run
away with you to accomplish this you
must be able to separate the real from
the unreal sounds easy enough
but often difficult to do even for those
with the strongest kind of emotional
fibre even for those in the best
physical condition a good physical
condition and emotional stability are
two of the best advantages you can have
but sometimes the challenge is too great
in a matter of minutes
this pilot passed through two major
crises first the aircraft emergency
leading to the survival situation second
the survival situation itself then a
third crisis was superimposed injury
upon ejection now he could do only two
things try to keep his face out of the
water and hope that help comes
and it's going to take all the stamina
and guts he's got that pilots desperate
problem was complicated as yours might
be by injury suffering injury is
unfortunate enough but whether the
injury is minor or severe shock is bound
to accompany it sometimes it's the most
serious consequence of the injury it can
also be a serious aftermath of the
emergency experience itself without any
injury being present
this makes spending a moment on the
subject of shock worthwhile let's take a
look at in shock its symptoms and
treatment you must be familiar with both
these are some of the signs pulse
weakened gravid respiration rapid skin
pale cold and moist and if the patient
is conscious he may feel faint or dizzy
and he may be frightened Restless or
anxious now what do you do about it
let's take a look if the patient is
injured don't wait for symptoms to
develop make him comfortable conserve
his body heat but don't overdo it don't
give him fluids if he's unconscious or
if he's injured internally him that's
the other fella
the fellow you're going to help but what
about you you alone how can you help
yourself if you have an injury you can
expect shot therefore try to anticipate
it if you're able do for yourself what
you would do for others now here's
something else the word shock is used in
another way to describe the mental state
of a victim immediately following an
accident apathy and irrational behavior
are common you can expect this to happen
but even when you're alone you have a
good chance of shaking it your training
is already cure a man well indoctrinated
emergency procedures will usually be
guided by them even when day's training
imparts knowledge and knowledge is the
most effective antidote for the ills
real and imaginary inflicted on the
survivor and this includes one of the
most common feared fear is a natural
response to danger and nothing to be
ashamed of everyone who faces an
emergency which threatens any of his
important needs experiences fear in a
survival emergency you may be constantly
threatened with the loss of water food
shelter companionship yes even if life
itself your fear will greatly influence
your behavior and your behavior your
chances of survival you must recognize
it live with it and if possible use it
to your advantage
recognizing fear in yourself shouldn't
be too difficult
you've met it before and you've overcome
it but as you face survival fear
isolation remoteness loneliness and the
other psychological stresses are greatly
magnified coping with them requires a
greater effort but you can do it this
man did for twenty long days how was he
able to do it alone because he was
endowed with some kind of supreme wisdom
because he had courage far beyond that
allotted to the ordinary human being no
he had only the resources you have but
he used them to his advantage
he was afraid and he admitted him he
accepted his lot and he tried to improve
it
he kept busy he forage for food to
maintain his physical condition
and when he wasn't looking for food he
kept his mind alert by doing
mathematical problems and by singing all
the songs he could remember in order to
conserve his energy he exercised only
lightly but he exercised regularly he
was in an alien environment and he was
afraid but he didn't let fear take away
his will to live
he recognized the real dangers and each
of practical measures to eliminate them
and be active
that was a sequence from Air Force
training film deep-sea survival it
doesn't tell you everything you must
know no film camp it was designed
primarily to make you think and as I
said that was the purpose of this
discussion to make you think about these
things and how they might affect you how
much do you know right now about
survival and its physiological and
psychological stresses let's hope you
know more than this fellow
but what is his affliction fear panic no
he was suffering from thirst and
dehydration that he sneaked drinks of
seawater at night
compounding his problem the result
mental deterioration
[Music]
mental deterioration if he had taken the
trouble to find out he would have known
that it might kill him
don't let ignorant of survival stresses
be your mistake it's the biggest one you
can make
[Music]